laurent tu trouve qu'on donne trop la
parole à eric zemmour c'est pas à moi de
juger ça moi je vais donner un parent de
cinq ans c'était on le rappelle couple
il a changé on me le rab home le rabâche
toujours mais quand même génial vous
êtes vous avez donné et nan ça fait 10
ans ma disant que je ne lui donne plus
la parole mais attend de passer à autre
chose en ce qui me concerne moi je
donnerai plus la parole aujourd'hui
parce que je les fais je les fais
pendant cinq ans mais c'est pas à moi de
décider si aujourd'hui d'autres doivent
lui donner la parole ou pas moi je sais
ça ne me choque pas plus que ça parce
que j'ai toujours été pour moi la
pluralité des avis des opinions
contrairement à ce qu'a dit monsieur
messi a tout à l'heure la preuve c'est
que quand eric zemmour était sur le
plateau moi j'étais pas du tout d'accord
avec ce qu'il disait un eric naulleau
j'imagine la plupart du temps non plus
même si après il s'est créé une
complicité qu'on connaît puisqu'il
travaille toujours ensemble mais avec
paula que c'est par là et polak était de
gauche zemmour était de droite
bon au bout de cinq ans moi j'en avais
assez parce que j'avais pas envie de
faire campagne ça c'est la vérité c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me suis
séparé d'eric zemmour en 2011 de 11
voiliers 2011 assure un nom avant 2012
j'avais pas envie d'avoir exercé pendant
la campagne présidentielle 2012 ça a été
mon choix est celui de catherine barma
cette séparation c'est moi c'est mon
choix donc aujourd'hui
évidemment que je donnerai pas la parole
l'invité pour un livre c'est pas
interdit en france mais mais comme
chroniqueur non moi j'ai fait mon temps
voyez laurent est ce que tu regrette pas
du tout d'avoir arrêté le duo naulleau
zemmour
non parce que d'abord on tourne en rond
au bout d'un moment les chroniqueurs
tous aussi bons qu'ils aient pu être
voilà on démarre aux défis sept éric
avait l'extrême rémois n'en parlons pas
aymeric caron avait l'esial natacha
polony sté l'éducation et ainsi de suite
au bout de trois ou quatre ans on
rabâche donc comme je peux pas me
changer moi il a dit vous étiez secteur
dernièrement je vais papier qui a dit ça
eric c'est oui m'enfin bon alors écoutez
c'est un compliment venant de sa bouche
patrie vraiment je pense que il sait ce
que ça veut dire bien paul valéry je
parle du secteur lui donner la parole
pendant cinq ans valérie une question
laurent est ce que tu trouves que il a
évolué et dansé dansé dans ses pensées
dans ses prises de positions entre le
moment où il était sur le plateau est
aujourd'hui évidemment évidemment
d'ailleurs il n'a je le rappelle eric
zemmour n'a jamais été condamné pour
aucun propos qu'il ait pu tenir
sur une autre plateau d'on n'est pas
couché ça il faut quand même le rappeler
ça s'est passé ensuite sur les plateaux
thierry ardisson ou ailleurs et voilà et
c'est assez drôle et c'est bien voilà un
autre exemple de la folie médiatique et
du surtitrage des journaux je devrais
parler tu es 7 jours si vous m'accordez
30 secondes c'est pourquoi j'espère bien
ne pas trop ami avec eux télé7 mais moi
je vais me fâcher parce que alors qu'il
ya deux jours je suis athée loger chez
saab sûr qu'eric naulleau la vue est
sûrement émoussé je suis interrogé chez
eric dussart et jade ce week-end chaud
airtel brad est sûr des tas de sujets
comme ici chez vous et abandonné zemmour
arrive et on me dit on me demande est ce
que vous pensez que c'est normal qu'eric
zemmour soit toujours un an ted
après tout est bien après ces
accusations d'agression sexuelle
alors là je réponds écoutez franchement
il ya d'autres raisons pour lesquelles
on pourrait elle cessé de mettre à
l'antenne
zemmour est par exemple racisme pour
lequel il ya plus de présomption
d'innocence
en revanche pour les agressions
sexuelles et aucune preuve ya pas eu de
jugement donc pas pourquoi ces news
l'enlèverai de sa chaîne pour ces
raisons-là titre de télé 7 jours
laurent wauquiez défend eric zemmour si
on défend régis roch que vraiment cette
drôle de façon
c'est une défense de l'as et une défense
de la démocratie c'est la seule réponse
démocratique possible ou alors on
considère que twitter remplaça justice
on est d'accord voilà que la sentence
est rendu en même temps que c'est pas
parce qu'on ne partage pas les opinions
de quelqu'un et c'est mon cas jamais sûr
partager une opinion devait moore et je
le trouvais sur le plateau quand je
l'avais en face de moi avec vous et eric
naulleau
je sais pas parce qu'on partage pas les
opinions quelqu'un qu'il faut l'accabler
de tous les maux face et on est chez les
fous là et eric